- It'll be okay sister.
There's always hope
tomorrow'll be taco night.
- Tomorrow's beef and noodles.
- Or beef and noodles (laughs).
I am so getting raptured first.
I've technically died on
three separate occasions
and I met God, dude fucking loves me.
I don't believe in getting sick.
- Wow, mind over mucus huh?
- Yeah, that and I
stockpile from commissary.
I'm on a cough syrup cocktail
that'll make Little Wayne
vomit in his dreads.
- What kind of a woman doesn't
want to pick her own date?
- Someone who doesn't get
excited by the wedding
and dove show complex and
society's bullshit need
to infantalize grown women.
Oh yeah, do your vitamins usually
have an identification number on 'em?
It's pharmaceutical grade speed.
- The bottle says vitamins
who am I to question it?
- So if I just take a shit in a can
and then I label it chili,
are you gonna eat that?
- Oh, that is a horrible image.
- We got trimmings from the
factory, 50 cents a pound.
- Trimmings, shit no one else wants.
That's a bag of turkey
assholes right there.
I hate it when you talk sometimes.
No, all the time.
- Is SHU really that bad?
- It's just like the Hamptons
only fucking horrible.
- SHU must really suck ass.
- Oh man, she was in there for two weeks.
I've taken shits longer than that.
One of these days you're gonna have
to change your panties Chapman.
That shit's gotta be getting ripe.
- I read that you're not
supposed to ask that.
- You read that?
What you studied for prison?
- We all have our shit Nicky.
- Yeah, some shit stinks worse
than other shit princess.
- You don't know how my shit smells.
- Sure I do (sniffs) your
shit smells like Shalimar.
So you and me, we're like
snatch sisters now, right?
- Can we not talk about
my ex-girlfriend's vagina?
- I hate to be a stickler here
but isn't it more like
ex-girlfriend, mistress, life-ruiner?
- Also I don't know anything about pumps.
- Hey, that's what he said.
Come on, I can't make one stupid joke
before I die from drowning?
- What the fuck are you
doing in there Nichols?
- I'm making you a glory hole Luschek.
- By all means carry on.
I fucked Judy King.
- Oh, we are talking about
Judy King the celebrity right?
Not some scabby, toothless
crack whore by the same name?
I'm not interested in running
some sweaty, fallopian relay race.
Look at this, like an art form.
I'm a sexual Steve Jobs and
that bitch is worth 10 points.
I don't know what your secret
is Specs but you are looking
even hotter than I remember.
- Suck it Nichols.
- Come on, you're single, I'm single.
The birds are singing, the grass is soft.
It wasn't exactly new
when I rode in all right,
a little dented actually, right?
The upholstery was worn.
- You knew I was after that.
- What can I say, not
everyone wants a diesel dyke?
- No more hugs, you're maxed out.
- What about pussy licking?
Is that an option?
Just to, get reacquainted, no?
- I am not easy.
- You're slutty not easy, there's
a difference semantically.
I was arrogant, it's a
classic story of hubris.
I'm like Icarus who's wings melted
before he could fuck the sun.
- No, softball is the
furthest thing from my mind.
- Oh no, let me clear, by
softball I meant two in her front
and then one in the butt
and then just like eating the pussy a lot.
'Cause you like it so much.
- [Piper] Let me explain something to you.
- And playing with the titties.
It's not an addiction, it's
a collection, all right?
Some people collect buttons,
or Taco Bell chihuahuas.
I collect orgasms, I'm all about giving.
Look, I am like a
bean-flicking Mother Theresa.
You like pussy Piper?
Or you prefer pipe as your name suggests?
I'm feeling some sapphic
vibes coming off you.
(sniffing)
Come on sister, you know
you would have gone my way
if you hadn't married Jesus.
I have been feeling a little tense lately.
Maybe if I stick my dick in your mouth
it might help me relax.
What, too hetero?
- Sometimes I feel like you're trying
to climb inside my womb.
- What can I say I've got mommy issues.
- That's not very classy.
- We're having sex in a fucking chapel.
Come on you wanna give me blue balls?
Oh you didn't hear?
We're done, well she's gotta
start working on tightening
her pussy muscles 'cause her
fiancee's dick is so small
it's like a hotdog in a hallway.
She came running to me
like an injured lamb.
Yes a lamb with great sexy
glasses and giant, pillowy tits
inside of my mouth.
(banging)
- Watch yourself Chapman.
- What, you gonna beat
the shit outta me now too?
Just tell me the safe word.
Listen if you want I can help
you forget what day it is.
You know, or your name for that matter.
If we don't get this stuff outta here
it's gonna find it's way
back to me, or me to it.
You know, I'm like a
bloodhound for oblivion.
- Nicky what happened,
where did this come from?
I thought you were doing okay?
- Wow, I'm a fuck up, huh?
- You know you could have come
to me if you were struggling.
- I know.
- Then why didn't you?
- 'Cause it's not what I do, okay.
I love you.
You know to be honest
I never really believed
in this bullshit before.
You know, I'd go to rehab and
no one told me that you guys
give it away for free in here.
I should have just gotten
locked up like a decade ago,
save my momma's suitcase of cash.
- Oh.
- Okay, that's enough.
- Red, this guy's serious.
- I'll take the shot.
Some things can't be rushed.
- She's your mom?
- Ah, maternal figurehead, my
actual mother lives in Brazil
with her boyfriend Paulo
who destroys rainforests
and collects photorealistic art.
She is a cunt, I am an embarrassment.
- I think it's the sobriety thing.
It's got me all riled up.
- You don't have to tell me, all right,
I've already come four times
today, it's not even noon.
- [Woman] The hair, it's
messy, unpolished, unkempt.
- My hair is clean.
- It's wild and slovenly.
- As long as it's not uptight and boring.
According to this aptitude test
I should be a professional athlete,
a park ranger or a correctional officer.
You just told an inmate in prison
that she should become
a correctional officer.
What the fuck is wrong with you?